on Saturday May 30th Elon Musk's SpaceX
successfully launched two astronauts
into space becoming the first crewed
orbital flight for American soil since
2011 even more significant is the first
time that astronauts traveled to orbit
on a privately-owned spacecraft previous
space tourism stunts have either been
suborbital or provided by the Russian
government veteran NASA astronauts Bob
Behnken and Doug Hurley lifted off from
the Kennedy Space Center in Florida
less than a day later arrived at the
International Space Station where they
will remain for four months thankin and
Hurley hitched a ride on a dragon
capsule launched by a Falcon 9 rocket
the pair was conveyed to the launch pad
on Tesla manufactured electric cars
outfitted in fashionable white and black
spacesuits and equipped with the
touchscreen operating system the launch
made history it was a triumphant moment
for musk in this california-based
company but this isn't just a victory
for one billionaire in one company it's
a culmination of a decade's long effort
to transform space into a new frontier
of entrepreneurship through the decades
following the Apollo program in the
1960s the u.s. saw a mini boom of space
entrepreneurs founding rocket companies
these efforts however were frequently
met with resistance from policy makers
and legacy industry most ended in
failure determined Musk founded SpaceX
in 2003 the funds form is previously
co-founded companies including PayPal
and zip2 later that year he unofficially
unveiled his company's early Falcon 1
rocket the first privately developed
liquid fuel launch vehicle to go into
orbit around the earth in 2004 Congress
passed legislation that helped
clear a regulatory path for commercial
launch companies by 2006 NASA changed
the way it did business through the
commercial orbital transportation
services program rather than taking the
lead on engineering the space agency
identified transportation capabilities
and invited companies to bid on meeting
them SpaceX sees the opportunity
winning a contract with NASA in 2006
that provided it with 270 million
dollars to develop its Falcon 9 rocket
this rocket successfully launched for
the first time in 2010 the company
signed a separate 1.6 billion dollar
contract with the space agency to send
cargo to the international space station
a contract it began fulfilling in 2012
when its Dragon capsule became the first
private spacecraft to dock with the
station as a decade moved on SpaceX
began offering launch services to other
commercial customers such as
telecommunications companies at
drastically lower prices than its
competition success with cargo convinced
NASA to embrace a market driven approach
to returning human spaceflight to
American soil
investors flocked in 2014 NASA awarded
contracts recruit commercial space
flights to two companies Boeing and
SpaceX combined the two contracts are
worth up to about 6.8 billion dollars
nASA has not been completely hands-off
in the development of these spacecraft
rather seeing them as a collaboration
this partnership while tense at times
was codependent and mutually beneficial
as demonstrated by the successful
docking of the astronauts at the
International Space Station next stop
the moon as part of NASA's Artemis
program SpaceX has been selected as one
of three companies developing human
Landers for astronauts to land on the
moon safely with Jeff Bezos founded Blue
Origin as a second in Huntsville Alabama
based Dianetics the third for SpaceX
landing on the moon will be accomplished
with it's still in development starship
the spacecraft become
also wants to use to eventually send
astronauts to Mars